[Music]
what do you think your opponent's
strengths are I have huge respect for
Sam
I mean he's generally his consistent
improvement in chess he's a
understanding working in general I think
we have pretty contrasting styles
despite the same rating almost exactly
so I think it should be a really
interesting match to play and to watch I
think he's a great intuitive player and
the reason I chose Hari Krishna is
because I haven't played much chess
against tonight ought to be very
interesting to to face him a bit more
over the board and especially the long
match you get a lot of experience
against a player it's a great
opportunity for me to play against such
a world-class player and who just played
against Magnus Carlsen three months ago
so I'm really looking forward to this
match yeah Chris off to do raw is a
young player I think he's 19 or 20 now
and he's played very well he's very
quick for short he's the beast in a
short of time control and I'm happy when
I'm playing bullit online chess
tournament on chess calm he beat car
yakin and Grizz Chuck before losing to
Wesley and then in the world blitz in
Rapid he actually finished second in the
blitz portion ahead of myself sort of
has a different style than I think most
the other top players he's a little bit
less solved likes to play all sorts of
different opening and for that reason
I'm really looking forward to the match
I mean okay he's one of the strongest
American players both Americas and very
solid and he's being rolled as far as I
know he's been involved - blade champion
which met make him very dangerous he's a
very strong player obviously despite the
fact that he
hasn't placed so much in the last few
years kind of like me he's still a very
strong player very aggressive in terms
of style maybe that's been top player
for a really long time I actually chose
him because I didn't want to pick
someone who's part of the grand gesture
because then I'll be playing them like
10 times this year he's a very strong
player very solid he knows Siri
extremely well he's quick calculates
well I mean he's a balanced player
personally I think he's a very good
irritation good the openings a very good
aggressive player who plays enterprising
Jeff who avoid short boring draw for a
lack of better word what do you think
your opponent's weaknesses are and how
do you plan on capitalizing on those so
just the whole game plan huh when does
this air before or after the match sure
okay
so I shouldn't say anything that report
will be able to use maybe it's weakness
I don't know so well and even if I knew
I would not would not disclose my
thoughts on this I know his weakness and
strength and I think it's not good good
idea to discuss them before before the
match anything else any well he's a very
good all-around player
you